[Musique]
alors qu'hier soir était diffusé un
nouveau numéro de l'émission top chef
sur m6 ce chacun pour soi aujourd'hui en
coulisses la prolongation du confinement
inquiète les producteurs et les
dirigeants de la chaîne qui sont dans
l'impasse
quant à la suite à donner au programme
si dès le début cette onzième saison du
programme a fait peur à ses producteurs
c'est parce que toutes les émissions
n'était pas encore monté il était
inquiet sur la façon dont il allait
pouvoir ajouter les voix off et les
réactions des chefs aux épreuves a
posteriori que la brigade de violette
n'a pas dit son dernier mot
on sera là on est toujours là après
avoir amené du matériel au domicile des
équipes du programme cette partie de
production a donc pu être résolus mais
aujourd'hui il reste un problème de
taille à résoudre comment réaliser la
grande finale de top chef c'est moi que
ça va
[Musique]
ça va être chaud ça fait quand même une
grande partie de cette finale a déjà été
enregistrée au four seasons hôtel george
cinq hôtels prestigieux dans lesquelles
les candidats ont dû préparer un repas
de choix mais il manque à ces deux
finales le moment fatidique celui de la
cérémonie finale et de l'annnonce du
vainqueur voilà on est pas dans la merde
généralement tournés au dernier moment
pour éviter tout de suite cette séquence
pose aujourd'hui question ni la
production ni la chaîne le savent quand
il sera possible de la réaliser et
l'horloge tourne a car la fin de la
saison approche
ces choix c'est très stressant une
grande inquiétude pour m6 qui se
demandent également si le chef paul
pairet nouvel arrivant de cette saison
pourra faire le déplacement depuis la
chine
paul pairet bien entendu on embrasse son
frère pierre
tout tout tout vous saurez tout sur le
zizi le vrai le faux les lbo ne dure le
bouquin un grand coup le lot touffu le
petit joue plus le rôle de l'europe et
le tout est ce que les chéris ça nous
chagrine
ou est-ce qu'on sent karl ffs le culte
est parti libéral a en tout cas moi
comme je regarde j'aurais bien aimé que
ça aille au bout mais je pense qu'on va
pas être possible effectivement pas le
père et pourra jamais revenir de chine
ça va être impossible de réunir tout le
monde est déjà ils galèrent là parce que
normalement vous savez les chefs ils
commentent l'émission voit donc chaque
semaine il court après les voies ou
d'échouer
ils essaient de chez eux ils sont de
chez eux ils font ça au fur et à mesure
moi je pense que ça n'ira jamais au bout
cette saison pas sincèrement non valérie
benaïm asie va de chats mais il ya bien
sûr que si ça ira au bout en bout là
maintenant on va retrouver
éventuellement la finale
en septembre il faudra juste patienter
c'est tout mais pas arrêté là avec tout
l'argent il a été mis sur la table cette
émission pour arrêter aux millions
disant désolé non et comme ça mais on de
rien mais mine de rien top chef a tué
masterchef
non mais c'est vrai je côtoie masterchef
est top chef en fait et je me rappelle à
l'époque il ya eu une indiscrétion comme
ça comme quoi tf1 allait faire cette
émission qui s'appelait masterchef été
dans un grand hangar tout ça et m6
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait car m6 vous
dis c'est des malins ils sont très forts
et
vont beaucoup plus vite que tf1 ça c'est
vrai on y voit là ça va plus vite parce
qu'il ya un chef là bas qui s'appelle
nicolas de tavernot qui va très vite et
thomas valentin c'est une équipe voilà
ils sont deux ils vont très très vite
donc forcément ils prennent très vite
les décisions c'est comme sur w9 d'agir
on craque pour très vite les décisions
et ils ont dit bah tu sais quoi on a
appris qu'elle est sa banon va créer
notre propre programme et on va faire
top chef et ils l'ont lancé avant
masterchef éminent à tf1 est arrivée
après et c'est vrai que m6 ont réussi à
créer un format plus fort que le format
original qu'est masterchef
ça a été ça à la ford n 6 et top chef a
continué et masterchef
bien entendu est devenu master chouf et
voilà ça cartonne au maroc mais vraiment
dans l'est dans les souks au maroc c'est
tout mais ça cartonne nulle part
ailleurs mme ashton schumann match ou
alors winzenrieth plus masterchef si je
me suis dit les professeurs alors que
top chef c'est avec des amateurs c'est
l'inversé il ya vingt jours
merci mon tuteur au sol et c'est de la
télé ça fait onze ans avec moi oui vous
êtes meilleurs vous êtes meilleurs en
implants capillaires
non mais c'est sûr quand on fait une
émission sur un rat implants capillaires
canton fera ne touche pas mais en plan
tout ce trip et les pmi et battu viendra
l'année prochaine laurence haye oui
c'est génial ses émissions parce que
savard motive les gens à cuisiner et
c'est hyper important parce que les
français cuisinent et c'est tout moi qui
signa je te dire au passage et ben en
tout cas toutes les meilleures en
politique que pour donner ton avis aux
[Rires]
rédacteurs a priori d'après ce que j'ai
vu normalement à deux prêts à aller
jusqu'au bout
est ce qu'ils sont entrain m6
effectivement de mettre en place un
système comme vous faites tous les soirs
de visioconférence donc effectivement ça
aura pas de saper la même saveur parce
que normalement les chutes sont avec
leur nom et à et voilà avec on va voir
15 kg
oui c'est pour les implants capillaires
ont versé pour
ah ah non je voulais dire que m6
contrairement à un pêcheur a eu la bonne
idée de faire c'est des professionnels
dont c'est une très bonne idée géniale
pensez-vous pas finale de top chef va
être pas dû et oui à 54% de 1 46%